president trump boasting that he won the
first debate as big changes could be
coming to the next one
the commission says it will adjust the
format to avoid chaos and interruptions
with new tools to maintain order
one possibility being discussed is to
give the moderator the ability
to mute the microphone of one candidate
while the other's talking president
trump blasting the idea on twitter
why would i allow the debate commission
to change the rules for the second and
third debates
when i easily won last time and a source
telling art john roberts that the biden
campaign is behind the request to cut
the mics
as for tuesday's rowdy debate the
candidates aren't done talking about or
taking shots at each other president
trump touting his performance and
mocking sleepy joe
i really enjoyed last night's debate
with sleepy joe
last night i did what the corrupt media
has refused to do i held joe biden
accountable for his 47 years of life
47 years of betrayal and 47 years of
failure i held joe accountable for
shipping your jobs and dreams abroad
and for bowing to the violent mob at
home
and biden continuing to whine about the
debate
it couldn't be a more stark difference
from what i saw last night in that
debate stage a
self-entitled self-serving president
who thinks everything is about him
he thinks that if he just yells louder
and louder
throws out lie after lie after lie he'll
get his way
and nancy pelosi is repeating her calls
for biden to back out
it was a sad occasion uh so i you know
people say well they should had a button
that turned one
microphone off while the other person
was speaking whatever it is i think one
and done
all right juan let me just ask you a
question about the rule change
proposals if biden won the debate
and that's how the debate was kind of
rowdy
why wouldn't he want those rules to stay
the same
he can just sit back let trump
self-destruct
and act like a bully and look bad in his
opinion and he can win another debate
it tells me they know they didn't win
and they're trying to now mute the
president
wow that was interesting because your
initial thoughts to me i was thinking
this is unlike jesse oh you see what you
did there
yeah why is jesse giving good advice
here and then of course you came back to
but of course
what do you think why you know if you if
you won if biden really thinks he won
well why wouldn't he want to keep the
rules the same i don't think the actor
here necessarily is biden
by the way i think the actor is the
presidential debate commissioner but he
made the request no he didn't no he
didn't
didn't he told roberts no what he what
you get here is a situation where
the american people clearly were
ill-served by what took place
on tuesday night you did not if you're
watching you did not get a clear vision
from either candidate of what it is that
they propose to do in the next four
years
and if you had your children with you
you were appalled i mean that was an
embarrassment
so i think that there's an effort here
to say how can we make the debate
actually
more productive and more valuable to the
american people
now the trump campaign not the biden but
the trump campaign is the one says we
don't want to change the rules i think
it was jason miller today said
oh they went after the debate commission
by the way again no it's not by they
went after the debate commission they
said
these people are permanent swamp
monsters
and of course for someone who's been
around a while like me i think
gee frank farenkov runs the debate
commission
he was the republican chairman the
national committee chairman
in the 1980s so how what are you you're
going after fellow republicans you know
what
it tells me degan that they have to
change the rules for
trump it's not like this would happen if
trump weren't
the nominee i mean they're they're not
gonna have mute buttons
in 2024 and then and on onward
right so it looks like it's trump
targeted it's of course this
trump targeted but this rule change
could help trump help himself you think
so yeah because he will focus on the
most
important issue the economy talk about
the deregulation and the tax cuts and
the leveling of the playing field
for corporations talk about the wealth
gap in income
inequality finally starting to shrink
something that didn't happen
under biden and obama talk about lower
and middle income folks finally
sharing in the wealth median household
income going up the most
last year at the fastest pace on record
year low on the poverty rate i can go on
but i just want to tell people something
growing up in the south
you might mute me but i can communicate
really effectively with my hands
so you could do a this or to biden or
even uh
like this just to distract them enough
just some options hey wait a second what
did that last one mean well it usually
makes a noise one but
it said uh dana you were saying you know
if they do have the mute button and it's
two minutes
two minutes and it's a little bit more
organized and disciplined
trump stays in the lane and he does what
he does
and that might help him yes i mean i
think that was the thing that
president trump um he was champing at
the bit
and so he didn't let biden try to finish
and as we've seen
if you think about those primary debates
um there were moments when joe biden
would
have two minutes to answer and then he
would get to about a minute 13 and be
like
yeah i'm good here and i think at that
point the president could be like
no please finish right and that's where
you might get a moment
that's right so we but we've gone from a
debate about whether there should be
debates or whether there were going to
be debates now we're having debates
about
the debate format i'm going to predict
that nothing changes
nothing changes nothing is going to
change for any of these debates it is
all going to stay the same
going forward i also just want to point
out that in the intro
we were playing sound of joe biden at an
event in which he's been being
praised for it like keeping his cool and
not yelling during the debate
and now here he is by himself at a
podium with
two huge microphones and he's yelling
louder than ever and he's basically
wiping out
from algebra right he's canceling out
all of those other
things it's that was a very bizarre
thing you don't need to yell
when you have your microphone and uh
didn't look like there was much of a
crowd there either greg
but that what you're talking about is
the same thing the media did today so
you had yesterday the media was
screaming
about how unsophisticated and
professional and horrible the
the debate was and then you see him at
the press conference right
yes with kaylee just over the top like
demanding ritual denunciation right now
i was watching the press conference with
kaylee
and i'm going this reminds me of when
the black lives matter activists
surround a car and they demand you say
black lives matter or you can't drive
away
that's what they were doing to kaylee
you must say it it was this
subjugation and nobody should ever give
in to that
nobody even if you agree with him it's a
principle you cannot be forced
to say something especially if you've
already said it a dozen times
so we're letting the media shape this
narrative it's driving me nuts
the narrative is that trump's the
problem and he needs to be put in a box
said it before it has the it was a no
rebuttal structure
that caused this so if you know that
you're not going to be have any chance
for a rebuttal and somebody says
something really personal about you
that those are fighting words you got to
jump in and if
you know you can't do it and by the way
by did interrupt before
trump but trump had to interrupt more
because there were more personal things
that
said to him so the problem wasn't trump
it was the no rebuttal
i'm not surprised the media wants a mute
button the or the the democrats want a
mute button because if you look at
college campuses yeah the left are
trying to shut down speech
they uh try to cancel shows they try to
cancel speakers
uh so they don't they don't want to
cooperate or communicate with people
that's the thing they don't like
competition to their opinions so they
prefer to just mute you and
mute you especially trump and they're
not mad at trump because he's mean
they're mad at trump because he's mean
on behalf
of millions he's their agent and they
remember they hate his base as much as
they hate trump so they they hate the
fact that he's so persuasive and so good
at this
i can't wait for the next debate you
know when you look at
what i was talking about was the
american people being ill-served yeah by
a bunch of
just people screaming and being rude to
each other that a lot of people
and this may actually benefit president
trump just got turned off by it
and i think you see this in the numbers
like you know you know you respect i
expected even a bigger audience than we
were able to get we got a great audience
but it was
you know i think a lot of people just
said what's all this shouting why is
trump constantly breaking up and being
rude here's my response
as contentious as the five gets
our ratings are always better when we go
at it i hate to say it
but that's true i mean they have us here
for a reason because people like to see
the fireworks
not everybody not everybody nobody wants
to hear about policy
if there's fireworks outside right and
that's
that's the reality that that is that
debate
is the ex is basically the consequence
or results of our success
although i i would like a mute button on
this show once in a while
mostly for dana i wanna mostly for dana
to keep dana in line
all right coming